كلاب الروبوتيه اصحابها يعاملونها
كالحيوانات الاليفه لها اسماء وعائله
ويحتفل باعياد ميلادها ليس هذا فقط بل يتم
التبرع باعضائها وتقام لها الجنائز
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
في اليابان الروبوتات ليست كمديلاتها في
دول العالم هنا تدلل ترفه وتعيش حياه تشبه
حياه اي حيوان اليف يربى في منزل ملاكح
فمع تقلص اعداد الاطفال هنا وصعوبه تربيه
الحيوانات الاليفه لدى البعض خصوصا كبار
السن قررت عائلات اقتناء كلاب روبرتيه
فاقمت الصداقه معها واعتبرت ضمن افراد
العائله لكن من اين جاءت فكرته هذا النوعي
من الروبوتات شركه سوني للالكترونيات بدات
صناعتها هذه الروبوتات المتطوره عام
واطلقت عليها اسم ايضا واقبل اليابانيون
على شرائها بكثافه في العشرين دقيقه
الاولى التي تلت الاعلان عن هذا النوع
الروبوتاتك بيعملها نحو ثلاثه الاف رغم ان
سعرها زاد عن 2000$
[موسيقى]
هذه الحيوانات القاتره على تطوير شخصياتها
والتنقل والحديث والتعبير عن فرحها وحزنها
انتشرت بشكل كبير في اليابان وبلغ عدد
ملكها نحو 150.000 شخص عام 2015
هذه الكلاب الروبوتيه لها اسماء وعائلات
وتقام الاحتفالات في اعياد ميلادها كما
وكانها حيوانات اليفه بالفعل هنا مثلا
احتفال غير مالوف ملاك الكلاب الروبوتيه
تجمع قرب هذا الضريح بصحبه حيواناتهم
للدعاء والصلاه واتمنى الصحه والحرض
السعيد لكلامهم
لكن هناك رجل سلبي لتربيه الكلاب
الروبوتيه فالشركه المنتجه توقفت عن
تصنيعي بعض الاصدارات منها وبالتالي اصبح
من النادر اصلاحها في حال توقفت عن العمل
ففي هذه الحاله يعلن الملاك وفاه كلابهم
ويتم التبرع باعضائها الصالحه لكلاب
الروبوتيه اخرى والغريب اقامه مراسم
جنائزي لها شهدوا ماذا يحدث في هذا المعبد
البوذي مثلا تم اشعال البخور وحضر الراهب
اليد والصلوات وللدعاء للرباط الراحل وسط
مشاعر حزينه لملك الرباط
شاركونا ارائكم هل تصبحوا الكلاب
الروبوتيه بديلا شائعا للحيوانات الاليفه
قريبا
[موسيقى]